i never believed i was an entrepreneur
and i never thought i wanted to be one
because in my heart of hearts i'm an
artist first in my heart of hearts i'm a
content creator i'm a thinker i'm a
visionary i'm an artist that's why i
really identify with being but what i
realized very quickly was
if you just wanted to be that and you
were going to wait to find people to
spot your talent teach you everything
about business and make every decision
for you
it was never going to happen and i think
a lot of artists are waiting to be found
and discovered and managed and molded
and that their agents going to change
their life and i'm like that doesn't
work like that you have to do the work
yourself you have to do the work
yourself yeah and so it's very well said
by the way for someone that actually is
in the position helping people and doing
that a lot of people think they don't
have to do the work but you 100 have to
do the work yourself yeah and i just
meet so many people and i love my
manager i love my agents i've got a
great team of people around me but they
are able to do more for me when i do
more for myself so well said and and i
find that so many people and me included
at one point i was waiting i thought
someone's gonna find me and then they're
gonna like change my career and change
my life and guess what that didn't
happen yeah and i realized that i had to
invent and i had to create and i had to
push so becoming an entrepreneur for me
was learning
because i was like i don't want to be
left behind and i don't want to be the
person that doesn't reach my potential
which means i'm gonna have to learn
skills i never thought now funny story
when i was 16 and i was hanging out in
the wrong circles i used to import
jackets from china and sell them at
school and all of this kind of stuff so
i was like i had a hustler i had i had
that in me but i forgot that and this is
what happens that when you go to school
and university and family you forget
who what your natural dial was so for me
i started reading books i started
spending time with people who were
successful in the area i wanted to learn
i went and shadowed people i got
mentored by people did you intern at all
i didn't intern afterwards but i
interned a lot when i was uh
at college in university but then since
then like in the last few years i think
it's mainly been picking up the phone to
people getting to know people and this
is what i've realized if you're putting
out content
and people can see you they're more
likely to pick up the phone and connect
and i had this experience where i went
out to someone and they didn't realize i
recognized them so i got invited on this
podcast in new york
and it was an influencer from linkedin
and he didn't know i knew him because he
he found me a different way and booked
me through someone else but when he met
me i was like dude i know you i see your
content on linkedin
and and he me you know he was shocked
that i even knew he was but i was like
i've seen you i see how you tell stories
and i think you're gonna grow and become
an incredible linkedin thinker one day
but i see it now and i'm like i was more
likely whereas if there was someone i'd
never heard of i probably wouldn't have
gone on yeah yeah and so i feel like
when you're putting out content when
you're creating and sharing what your
perspective is you're more likely to
attract the right energy around you
rather than when you're waiting for
someone to just discover you need
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
nation hey it's evan carmichael and i
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
jay shetty and my take on his top 10
rules for success enjoy
rule number two experience life what was
the thing that made you choose to
actually commit on such a deeper level
i think it was that when i was doing the
two lives i got to see what life looked
like at both ends yeah so i got to see
what like a cool life working in the
city wearing a posh suit to work every
day driving a fast car
you know
having a beautiful girlfriend at the
time like all that kind of stuff i got
to see what that felt like yeah and then
i got to see what it felt like living as
a monk in india and it's so weird to say
it and this is why i believe that more
people should have what i call immersive
experiences like when you think you want
to be an entrepreneur that's different
go and work with an entrepreneur for a
week and then think if you like the
process yeah not the result right like
don't look at the chains in the car in
the home
look at whether you like what time that
person wakes up like we're in the gym
every week together yep right at the
same time every week we're committed
we're committed and i'm sure you'll hear
today we're in your space in your studio
like you're committed and i think
because i'd done that for four years
actually making the decision was easy
because i already knew what i was
getting myself into it's kind of like
dating versus marriage yeah it's like if
you've never dated you don't know you
want to spend the rest of your life with
someone yeah and so i had dated for the
last four years with both these lives
and then i was like okay i prefer this
one that's literally it now i'm not
telling you to cheat on people and date
two people at a time the analogy applies
to this but the point being that if you
go and experience life decision making
becomes easy if you're trying to do all
of a theory in your head of like crap do
i become a monk or do i become a finance
person like you'd never figure that out
yeah but when you go live and you're
like oh wait a minute i felt happier
doing that yeah and that's what it was i
felt happier i felt i was gonna have a
bigger impact on the world because we
were not just meditating all day we were
building food distribution programs
charity philanthropy programs like we
were doing work in the world to help
people yeah and that's where i got most
activated like i'll tell you what
actually this is it this is the true
answer the reason why i decided to
become monk was i wanted to study
everything about philosophy and life and
i wanted to be able to live it for real
and so i was addicted to learning about
wisdom yeah and the second thing was i
was like i want to use my life to have a
meaning and impact in the world and at
that point in time i'd not seen people
do that through business i'd not seen
people do it through entrepreneurship
and success yeah i'd only seen people do
it in that way and so now that's
different i believe you can have an
impact through business etc yeah but at
that time i'd not seen that rule number
three find your passion this is
something i created called the quadrant
of
potential what you'll see here is
the blue section says not good at and
not interested
when you do what you're not good at and
you're not interested in
it feels pointless and it can lead to
depression
when you do what you're not good at and
you're not interested in it can lead to
depression it can lead to anxiety it can
lead to all of those negative emotions
now look at the yellow section of the
quadrant
not good at but interested there's a lot
of stuff in the world that we're not
good at
but we're interested in
for me social media used to be one of
those things
i was interested in social media but i
wasn't good at it but that's something
where you see potential and you feel
excitement
when you're trying to learn something
that you're not good at but you're
interested in you feel a buzz it's
exciting
look at the gray section of the quadrant
the gray section of the quadrant is good
at but don't love
that's what most of us end up doing for
work
we do something that we're good at but
we don't really love it it doesn't
fulfill us
and that ends up being a profession but
it stresses us out and finally in the
orange quadrant you have good at and
love
that's where you find passion and that's
where you experience fulfillment
what i'd love for you to do is today
tomorrow sit down with your partner your
friend and actually reflect
on two to three things in each section
of that quadrant
do you know what you're good at and love
do more of that
do you know what that you're not good at
but interested in do more of that
spend your life in the orange and yellow
side of the quadrant and you will never
ever
have to experience that pressure that
stress anxiety in the negative sense
you'll still experience stress and
pressure
i experience stress and pressure but
it's good
it motivates me inspires me not bringing
me down
let's move away from spending time in
the good and don't loved and not good
and not interested rule number four
express gratitude i really believe that
the first thought you want to have in
the day is a thought of gratitude so
when we would wake up as monks at 4 00
am and our collective prayers and
meditations would start at 4 30 a.m the
first prayer of meditation was about
gratitude
and it was engineered in that way
because when you are present in
gratitude you can't be anywhere else
so if you're in a state of gratitude you
can't be in a state of anxiety if you're
in a state of gratitude you can't be in
a state of worry so many of us today
wake up in a state of worry in a state
of anxiety and so if your first thought
can be a thought of gratitude
it can absolutely transform your day and
so i'm actually going to ask you a
question melissa i want you to name
two friends they can be real or
imaginary but i need two names
um
rachel and amanda okay so rachel and
amanda disclaimer i do not know rachel
and amanda so anything i say about them
from now on is completely fictional but
let's take rachel and amanda so let's
say after all of this covered pandemic
lockdown is over melissa and her husband
throw a party and they invite rachel and
amanda now they have a good time and the
next morning
when melissa wakes up and looks at her
phone she sees a text message by the way
not straight away when she wakes up she
does all over morning reading i do my
meditation
meditations and then when she looks at
her phone she sees messages from rachel
and amanda
rachel says and again rachel none of
this is personal or or about you i
promise uh if you're a real person but
rachel says thank you melissa had a
great time now that's her message and
amanda's message when melissa reads it
says
melissa that was amazing what an
incredible party i had the best time
ever the the food was incredible and the
games we played were so fun your your
family and friends are all so beautiful
you know what you made my 2020. this was
amazing thank you so much
now melissa is a grateful person so
chances are she'll feel grateful for
both of those messages but it's likely
that amanda's message is far more
fulfilling to her heart because that
thankfulness for it to truly work for it
to scientifically boost your mood
thankfulness and gratitude needs to be
personalized and specific
so when we say we're grateful for the
air or grateful for our hands or our
body or our life
if it's not specific if it's not
personalized you don't actually feel the
effect of gratitude
you also don't feel the effect of
gratitude if it just lives in your
journal if it just lives in your heart
and mind it also needs to be expressed
and shared with people it needs to be an
exchange of energy and so the fact that
both her friends reach souther is great
but the one that's personalized and
specific goes a step further so remember
in your own gratitude practice and so i
try to make a point every day to choose
one person a day
to send a voice note to a text message
um a voice note a facetime call a video
message whatever it is one person a day
how can i express personalized specific
gratitude right that's that's all it
takes so that's a really key habit for
me
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five build good
relationships i was excited to come to
this conversation thank you because i'm
gonna get to learn from you we're gonna
bond we're gonna you know deepen our
connection like i'm gonna make a new
friend like i wanna be around that
energy i don't wanna walk into
environments where i'm constantly
feeling like oh god why am i here yeah
you know and so
we hear it all the time but genuinely
your relationships harvard's 75 year old
study suggests that human relationships
is the number one reason people are
happy or not i went to sardinia earlier
this year
middle of last year sardinia's in italy
it's a blue zone blue zones are the
places where people live the longest in
the world and the most amount of people
live over a hundred the number one
reason they said that is community
community community that's a big reason
why people live longer and live happier
lives so for me it's find that human
connection in community and please don't
settle for your family like it doesn't
have to be a family like you know there
are there are friends and then there's
family and then there are friends that
become family and my point is go find
that community like so many people are
like i hear this all the time jay my
family is negative i'm surrounded by a
negative environment i'm like yeah but
we don't live in a world where that's
your only option anymore yeah you can
find tribes and communities anywhere
rule number six practice forgiveness
when i look at forgiveness i define
forgiveness in this way to help you
the stages of forgiveness how many times
even in the past did someone hurt you
and you said i'm gonna get my revenge
in that voice
in front of a mirror
and recorded it now let's
any intention
that starts with revenge
will lead to pain
just understand that for a moment any
intention that you plan based on revenge
will ultimately not fulfill you
because revenge means the same person
that broke you has to fix you
and when we want revenge we want the
same person that broke us to fix us
because we're doing revenge which means
we want to show them how we change and
how we did it and how we got it right
and when you try and do that guess what
if that person doesn't feel you got it
right
you're still carrying it
if that person doesn't feel you got the
best revenge body if that the person
doesn't feel you've got the best revenge
business if that person doesn't feel you
got the best revenge car
you won't be satisfied
because revenge means that your metric
your reference point is still that
person
the person who broke you cannot fix you
and you do not fix yourself
by breaking someone else rule number
seven claim your own success ticket
what's one thing that we can do for more
wealth so more abundance in all the
areas of our life
so there's a beautiful beautiful
sanskrit word named mudata
and mudata means to feel joy in others
success
so it's been described that
we
know how to feel pain when other people
feel pain
that's what we call empathy or
compassion
but we don't know how to feel joy when
other people feel joy and in think like
a monk i talk about this because i talk
about how there are an infinite number
of seats
in the theater of happiness
but because we live in a finite world
have believed that there are only x
number of tickets in that concert
there are only x number of seats limited
number of seats in that sports game
there are only this many people that
have the opportunity to be abundant
wealthy and successful
and as soon as you put a limit in your
mind and believe that there are only a
finite number of seeds you can't enjoy
the show
and so mood it is the perspective of
saying if i can feel joy for someone
else's success and realize that takes
nothing away from me
because there's infinite number of seats
and actually forget infinite number of
seats there is a seat with your name on
it
there are tickets with your name on it
in the theater of happiness sitting
there waiting for you but because you
want someone else's seat so bad because
you're chasing someone else's seat so
bad and they're already sitting on it
your seats lying there empty
and so if you just claim your seat
and so if we can experience other
people's joy if we can uh
look to celebrate other people's
successes and joys then then
that will open up abundance in our life
a because we're now part of their
success have you ever noticed that when
you celebrate someone else's success
you're a part of their success so you're
doing that second you get to learn from
their journey see when you're envious or
you compare you don't get to learn so
you've lost everything whereas when you
celebrate someone you get to go oh what
did they do right
notice how if you're criticizing someone
who's one or you're negative towards
them you go oh well they've got i've got
nothing to learn from them it was easy
from them who cares about them but if
you go wait a minute
they got something right what do they do
you can learn from them so the first
thing is you're a part of their success
the second thing is you learn from them
or their journey
and the third thing is you realize that
there's a seat with your name on it and
if you can do that abundance and wealth
and everything will come
and and you start to follow your own
path as the gita says which i quote in
the book
it's better to follow your own path
imperfectly than to try to pursue
someone else's path perfect perfectly
and so allowing yourself to just chase
that seat that has your name on it is
far better than trying to get in someone
else's seat rule number eight don't rush
anything at one point one of your videos
got
365 million views right yeah one of them
what was that video that video is a
video where i'm talking about
not rushing people's timelines okay so i
feel like we've got and i was just
speaking to someone this week they're
like 25 years old and they feel the
pressure to be a successful entrepreneur
and have a multi-million dollar business
by age 30 and i'm like
why do you feel that pressure yeah but i
feel like now like you know when you're
21 you've got a pressure why don't you
have a million followers yet when you're
18 you've got a pressure like why am i
not a tick tock star yet right it's like
there were just so much pressure and
that video was all about how like some
of the most successful people in the
world became successful at 40 a 50 at 60
at 70. like there is no timeline on
success don't rush it don't rush it and
don't let anyone rush you yeah because
that's one of the biggest mistakes we
make is we go oh my friends already got
this i need to do it and when you start
living as a reflection of other people
you're not living the life you want
you're living the life they want no
questions so that's what the video is
about rule number nine be inspired i
think of inspiration like eating food
every day you feel hungry
and you don't panic when you get hungry
you just know you need to find food and
eat but you don't go oh no why do i feel
hungry today i ate so much yesterday and
i ate so much last week i shouldn't be
hungry today like why do i feel hungry
today that's not your panic your panic
is why didn't i plan for my meal right
like that's the panic but you're not
panicking going oh my gosh why am i
hungry i shouldn't be hungry
so it's really strange when we don't
feel inspired or motivated we we panic
we go oh no why don't i feel inspired
i'm i'm a negative person like i'm i'm
not motivated like what's wrong with me
well that's because we haven't fed
ourselves
and so we have to find something that
inspires us daily you may say
uh it's a quote that you see that you
write your favorite quote you put on a
post-it note next to your bed when you
wake up in the morning it may be a
paragraph from a book it may be
listening to this podcast
two of my best habits for inspiration
with these two that i want to share with
you melissa one of them was around
i probably said like around seven years
ago when i left the
when i left monk life i would every day
i would listen to steve jobs's stanford
commencement speech every single day to
the point where i almost knew off by
heart
and i cannot tell you how much that
rewired the voice in my head
and how much of that speech has inspired
every step and decision i've made today
i had the fortune the other day of
sitting down with matthew mcconaughey on
my podcast i was interviewing him for it
i think the episode comes out next
monday
and
i was telling him that at one point in
my life in about
i listened to his oscars acceptance
speech and it's about five minutes and i
would listen to it every single day for
30 days and it was so profound listening
to the same thing again and again and
again to rewire my mind so inspiration
can come in all ways whether you're an
auditory learner or a kinesthetic
learner or a visual learner the point is
you have to feed yourself every day
annual number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips is don't
gamble they found that 77
of those who struggle financially play
the lottery right they play the game
they gamble 77
of people who are struggling financially
gamble the advice is don't gamble if
you're gambling right and you're not
winning a lot maybe you're an online
poker player right maybe you're playing
for entertainment that's different but
still be careful but maybe you're
someone who's hoping that you're going
to get a quick rich scheme a lot of
these quick rit schemes online aren't
real right and and gambling is just the
more obvious version of that where it's
all gamified it feels exciting but they
found that 77
of people that are struggling
financially gamble right so the advice
was don't gamble don't focus in on that
the challenge is that we think
things
come with emotions
feelings we think things come with
feelings and emotions and guess what
they don't so if you chase money well
they might for a moment right or they
won't i don't think they even do also
it's such a false sense of feeling i
don't know maybe for a moment but it's
so short-lived that it's it's not even
worth counting almost so it's like when
you
when you think that i'm chasing money
guess what you will get money yep and
that's great money is really important
and money is a really important resource
but guess what money is not now going to
fill that gap that void that feeling
that emotion that you're missing in your
life what are most people missing we're
missing a deep sense of love i think i
think the biggest need in the world as
we've heard many times before from all
the ancient texts they they
summarize it like this to love and be
loved like that is the need of humanity
to love and be loved and when we don't
experience that we then start looking
for status we then start looking for
money then we then start looking for
recognition just to help us give the
feeling of false sense of love correct
and the challenge is because most of us
didn't experience that from our parents
and this is the key thing what we crave
in life
is what we did or didn't get from our
parents what our parents did give us is
what we continue to crave or what they
didn't give us is what we continue to
crave so you'll find that most people's
love languages that they chase
are things that their parents didn't
give them so if their parents didn't
give them time they now crave everyone's
time if their parents didn't give them
gifts they'd crave gifts if their
parents didn't give them
acts of service they're craving those
acts of service so it's because of our
childhood
and if we don't learn
to process all of that experience which
most people never get the time to do and
and i empathize with that because i've
had to go through that i've seen me
repeating my parents patterns i've seen
something you were craving so i would
crave a big thing for me was i would
crave surprises and gifts because that's
your thing yeah that's my thing still is
your thing they still might be yeah and
and i did your parents not do that for
you no they did my mom did a lot of it
that's why you're still crazy correct so
my mom would always every year on my
birthday
she'd always surprise me with the one
thing i wanted and i wasn't spoiled
growing up i didn't have a lot growing
up but she would get that one thing
whether it was like a power rangers toy
or whether it was whatever it was you
know something
yeah things you want as a kid right and
she would always surprise me with that
and that became so deep rooted now i'll
give you an example when i then married
my wife
you just expect people to know that that
they're going to do the same thing
totally and tonight
no because i'm expecting my wife to be
like my mom in the sense of i expected a
surprise or show me love in the same way
and she doesn't know that she's not a
mind reader i can't explain expect her
to know that so it took communication it
took time for me to explain that if
you've not done something for yourself
every day yeah if you've not taken your
time to invest in yourself every day and
that isn't just a
you know it's it comes so much from
understanding yourself
and understanding yourself comes from
the place of knowing yourself and
getting to know yourself and most of us
spend so much time codependency trying
to get to know someone else and what
their needs are anticipate their needs
and then shape shift so that i can be
what i think you want to totally evolve
yeah evolve and transmorph into this
person that will be the best for them
but what about if you did that for
yourself to start with and so most of us
don't even know what we want to eat for
dinner on a given day or like when our
favorite movies are we struggle we sit
there for like hours trying to figure
out what to watch
because we haven't really got to know
ourselves and so to me getting to know
yourself is very basic after you eat a
meal ask yourself did i enjoy that what
did i like about it did i feel great 24
hours after reading it after watching a
movie what did i like about it why did i
enjoy it those basic questions will give
you a much deeper understanding of
yourself pain makes us pay attention
right like pain makes you pay attention
i'll give an example if you're like if
you've got a little cut here
you you may not think anything of it if
the card gets bigger and it starts to
sting you take it a bit more seriously
now if this if it gets infected then
you're like okay i need to do something
about it and often there are these signs
in our life there are always signs
signals and reminders in our life they
are always there
but they're so quiet
and we're so loud that we don't hear
them
and so then those signals have to get
louder and deeper and harder to finally
get our attention because we're not
present with ourselves the only way our
body and mind get us to be present is
through pain
and so the only antidote is to be
proactively present with ourselves
is to actually sit with our emotions is
to actually get to know ourselves
intimately and personally because if
we're always rushing around and moving
around our body and mind don't have the
time to tell us what's going on we don't
listen to our mind and body because
we're too busy
and so when we finally listen to our
body and mind
then we get an opportunity to address
what's going on so to me that's why pain
makes us
stop and realize and forces it to happen
tragedy transforms us because it forces
us to pay attention
but we can change that
by proactively being present with our
minded body and that's how we can create
that urgency
without the pain and without the tragedy
spirituality and business is an
interesting concept because a lot of
people today see it as an oxymoron yeah
or
you know mutually exclusive
and the truth is that spirituality is so
powerful that it actually spreads across
everything and i know i know all of you
understand that but it's like
if spirituality is what we all say it is
then it has the purity and the power
to spread across anything
and again going back to our previous
theme the key element
is is this for service of humanity for
others or is this in the service of
myself now that's a fine line yeah and
i've been on the wrong side of that line
plenty of times so there's plenty of
times when i assess options and
opportunities in front of me and i
realize i'm only taking that option
because there's ego involved
i'm only taking that option because
there's an opportunity or there's a big
payout or there's a nice dollar sign
next to it and i'm only doing it for
that and i've said yes to stuff like
that plenty of times to know that i'm
not perfect but the awareness
is what i would encourage people to do
is is having the ability to be like here
are the three four options in my life
right now
let me write a word above them which is
the intention of why i'm choosing that
and if the if the word isn't love
or service
it's not going to feel good after i
finish it
and and so that's that's what i would
encourage people to do as a reflection
without needing anyone in their life or
anyone around them before i ever made a
video i pitched my video series idea to
40 media companies and i was rejected by
every single one of them before an
interview because i didn't have a media
or journalism background or a hosting
background or a communications
background and so 40 of the top media
companies said no immediately they
didn't even meet me they didn't take the
time i then chased two editors of huge
magazines and online magazines in london
one of them i chased while he was riding
his bike across london the other i
networked with at an event and i begged
them both for jobs and i said look just
give me a break i just need an
opportunity and this was when i was 28
years old three years ago and they both
said to me they said you're too old to
be in media like this is not going to
happen everyone trying to break through
is 21 years old it's not going to happen
so i had literally multiple doors closed
in my face before i even made a video
and i ended up this is in 2013 2014 this
is 2016. 2016 2016. and then i ended up
at a ethnic minority tv training day run
by the bbc in london and i walked into
this room and there were six colored
people in there and i was like oh i'm
brown you're brown and you're brown and
black and you know it was literally like
it was a room full of ethnic minorities
in in london and this was run for us and
they trained us in presenting i went
there to see if i even had the skills
and then afterwards they were just like
yeah jay you're great like you could do
this i was like great you have a job for
me and they said no no no no there's no
jobs in media and i was like okay great
so i got to a point where i'd exhausted
all options apart from starting a social
media page so i launched my first video
on social media on facebook and youtube
in 2016 just three years ago and what
were you doing outside of hustling in
that moment
i was doing a lot of corporate coaching
i was what gave you the confidence after
the after being rejected by 40 media
companies and being told that you're
good but there's no jobs what still
gives you the confidence to keep going
the only thing that gave me the
confidence was this principle of thought
by thomas edison which was when you
believe you've exhausted all options
remember this you haven't and i was
saying to myself that unless i've
genuinely knocked on every single door
i can't say to anyone that i haven't had
a chance
and so my confidence came from the fact
that i was going to try and knock on
every different door walk down every
different path and see what was possible
and that's my biggest advice to everyone
today is that we no longer need
permission from anyone to give us an
opportunity to share our voice the
audience and community can decide for
themselves
you've got people waiting on social
media for content the people will decide
for you and so for all of us today we
have this unique opportunity we were
left on the streets for 30 days to
offend for ourselves and to figure it
out just that's it you've got your
clothes that you're wearing there's no
money no food no shelter no nothing
figure it out
and
day one i'm like okay like you know
maybe it's a joke like maybe maybe
they're gonna come back at night and be
like no guys you know so i'm trying to
figure out what it is this is training
mode
and it's really interesting what what
your mind and body does so the first
thing your mind and body does when you
have nothing is you have fear
the first thing you feel is fear
and that we can all relate to in life
the first thing you feel when you all of
a sudden feel that your plan and you
have no nothing organized and you have
no structure and shelter and all of this
stuff that we now rely on you have fear
now the fact that you're there on your
own and you don't have a phone and you
can't just call someone up and you don't
know the city that you're in
your next thing is survival right fear
leads to survival mode so you're trying
to find food from everywhere you're
trying to hoard it you're trying to get
it from everywhere you're trying to keep
it you're trying to figure out like how
can i get lots of this so that i can
take care of myself and you start just
becoming crazy almost and it's funny
because those two experiences are so
similar to what you see in society today
yeah fear
breeds survival mode which breeds greed
and hoarding and wanting to have
abundance lack of abundance exactly and
so you do that in that scenario for like
remember this is a 30-day experiment
that's crazy so you do that for like the
first week
you do that for the first week where you
just want to find anywhere steel look
etc not steel trying not to steal but
like finding fruits of trees whatever
you're just trying to do whatever you
can finding anywhere to sleep and you're
offending for yourself it's all about
you
the interesting thing that happens in
week two is that you recognize
that
you recognize that you really want
to
when you make a difference in someone's
life they'll help you so by week two you
start recognizing if i help villagers if
i help this old lady if i help this old
man if i serve the people around me
then they'll give it to me anyway and we
saw people inviting us into their homes
we saw people giving us food we saw
people cooking for us just because we
were helping people wow and you start to
see community you start to see the value
of collaboration you start to see the
value of energy exchange you start to
learn
how your heart and soul leads to other
people giving you their heart and soul
and and you experience that now the
interesting thing is that goes on for
about two weeks and you think you've
kind of mastered it right and then the
biggest challenge comes when this is
what you're meant to grow to and this is
where you go beyond
feeling good about serving and getting
an exchange and this is not spoke about
as prominent today because i think we
live in a world where people aren't
self-loved and self-fueled enough to
even consider this
and so we talk a lot about self-love
today which i highly believe in we talk
a lot about non-judgment of yourself
today which i highly believe in but this
principle was beautiful we recognized by
the final week
that actually we were far stronger
and capable than a lot of people on the
planet a lot of people in the village
sorry that were disabled
that couldn't see that had lost their
eyesight they couldn't speak they
couldn't walk they'd broken limbs
and so by the end of it we realized that
when we served others and gained we
could actually give to those people
because they didn't have because they
weren't young men like we were they
weren't able men like we were they
weren't skilled like we were
and now so you can even go another one
you could go another level it wasn't
just that you could take yourself you
could go another level but those three
stages of transformation show us exactly
the three stages we need the first is
getting over your greed and ego the
second one is recognizing that you have
value and when you serve others there's
a value exchange and the third when
you're feeling full and overflowing you
can then overflow to others
and so for me that 30 days like has
transformed my life ever since
because i was able to experience all of
the experiences we experienced today but
in heightened mode like i didn't know
where i was going to sleep or i was
going to eat
and when you experience it at that
extreme
and you're able to work it out now in
with you have more perspective you have
more gratitude you have more ability to
navigate that emotion again and you
recognize that it is an emotion so for
me that was one of the most
transformative things that i've ever
done wow that's powerful yeah and it
just really took me on an internal
journey of overcoming fear overcoming
greed and always recognizing that you
can always go
that one step above and recognizing that
you don't you know as soon as you think
you've figured it out
you recognize that you haven't
and that there can be another level and
i think for all of us
that's a great reminder for me that when
i think i have it figured out
that's the biggest reminder of there's
still another level you've got to look
at that has happened so many times when
a video you think is gonna hit
and it doesn't and then there's a video
you're like that's never gonna hit and
it does
and
that's where i've reconciled myself down
is recognizing that i don't always know
what's gonna work and that's a beautiful
thing
and that i've been and i and i've been
feeling this often that
i've got to where i want in life just
not in the way i imagined it
and that's the beauty of
giving up that control
and feeling slightly liberated so i'll
give an example of what i mean by that
i'm always working strategically
effectively and impactfully in the best
ways i can but sometimes the place where
i put my most energy does the worst and
sometimes something that i tried on the
side like blows up and it's incredible
and that's where i've reconciled myself
down recognizing if i'm putting my best
foot forward and i'm working
strategically and effectively the things
that are going to work will work and it
may not be the things i expect and what
we're doing is or what i do sometimes
too is you're so focused on wanting one
thing to work you miss the fact that
there's like nine other things that are
happening that are amazing around you
that you could never have dreamed of
and i've seen that in my life countless
times where i wanted one thing to work
three things were working over here but
i was so like why is this not working
like why is this not working that you
missed that
so self-doubt for me is something that
i've tried to build a close relationship
with and i get it all the time i still
get it before a post before a video
before anything i mean i was just in you
know i'm working on my book right now i
just launched a podcast and before i
launched the podcast i had no idea how
well it was going to do how badly it was
going to do or anything and there was a
part of me that was like are people
going to listen to this like are people
going to care like i ask myself all
those questions still today
number one i'm glad i asked myself those
questions it means i'm human it means
that i care
it means that it's important to me i
speak at so many conferences and
everyone always asks me do you still get
nervous i go yes i get nervous because i
care the day i stop feeling nervous that
means i don't care anymore if i don't
care anymore that means i don't love
what i do anymore so for me the first
thing is i recognize that self-doubt
just shows me that i care and that
something's important to me whereas i
don't doubt myself around things that i
don't care about like if you ask me a
question right now about what's the
recipe for this amazing dish i wouldn't
know and i'd say i don't know and i'd be
okay with it because i don't care about
cooking i'm not a cook right but if it's
something that you care about you'll
you'll have self-doubt the second thing
that i do with self-doubt is i go okay
if that's the things that i'm doubting
myself for
what strategies what can i put into
place to overcome them doubt is just a
great way of making you check
what you need to work on so if my doubt
is oh my god not enough people are going
to listen to this so i'm like okay so
how do we make it more listenable how do
we make the content better how do we
make the conversation better if my doubt
is
um you know i don't feel like people are
going to like this topic okay what
themes am i good at talking about what
is you know it's it's a great checking
system to improve what you have so don't
look at self-doubt as negative
turn it into a positive by actually
asking yourself those questions right so
build a relationship with self-doubt
because it's never going to go away
right don't avoid it don't avoid it
definitely don't avoid it it's never
going to go away so if it's never going
to go away build a happy positive
relationship with it so my positive
relationship with it is you're showing
me
what i need to focus on to feel less of
that
and most of us feel self-doubt because
we're not researching we're not building
knowledge we're not building expertise
and i think that's the biggest thing for
me is when i feel self-doubt it's
because i i'll give a perfect example
when i was thinking about doing a
podcast and you're doing interviews
you don't just become an interviewer you
have to watch interviews you have to
absorb good interviewers you've you
can't just be an interviewee you have to
watch good interviewees and so for me a
lot of us start something and we feel
self-doubt because we've never learned
that skill or we've never observed that
skill
so my focus is if i want to be a good
interviewer i need to watch good
interviewers if you want to be a good
stage performer watch good stage
performers if you want to be a good monk
watch good monks right you don't become
something good without seeing it
so
self-doubt comes because you haven't
upskilled and the great thing today is
you can do an online course you can
upscale from here you can obscure from
there you can just listen to this
podcast and watch you guys who've done
it for such a long period of time that's
a seeing someone who's done something
consistently
that's the best way of getting good at
something and then your self-doubt will
disappear
so self-doubt can only be cut by the
sword of knowledge it can only be cut by
the sword of upskilling so that's where
it starts i personally also having
become a i feel like i've become even
more of a seeker since being involved
and that's opened me up to alternative
ideas alternative ways of thinking
learning from all different traditions
wherever i can and and i think that's a
really important part i think the
challenge with being a
immature seeker in my definition of it
is you find something it sounds cool and
you go that's it there's nothing else
and then a real seeker goes well that is
it but how can everything else even
enhance this and make this even greater
for me if this is where my faith is or
this is where my belief system is so i'm
someone who genuinely loves learning
from
people from all different walks of life
and backgrounds because i feel
if i was presented with a deeper more
meaningful philosophy and life structure
i would adopt it
that's why because i'm open to that love
is a doing word it's active it's a verb
and if love is a verb then service is
the action and that's why love and
service
have to be so intertwined because i feel
that today when we talk about love the
definition is so skewed
when people hear the word love that's
what the problem is that's what the
problem is that's why i prefer service
to love
because service is the activation of
love
when someone loves someone they serve
that's
how love works and
i think that's why when we talk about
love i agree
it's just because of phonetics
definitions
breaking it down
love has become so
badly abused like the word love is so
abused and misused in our lives it
really is right you say i love you to
people you don't love people use it to
manipulate people
we just throw love around right and as
much as it should be everywhere it's
also sacred
love's also sacred and that's why you
were able to experience it because it
was experienced through a sacred
mechanism you were able to experience
love yeah and i and i've never felt it
like that before because it also was
this sense of self-love as well yeah and
that's what you felt in jerusalem too
when you went and that's what i felt
and that's what i feel that we
experience love when it's through
service and engagement in that
atmosphere we don't just experience it
every single day you may have someone
who loves you deeply
you've just never articulated what your
love language is you have to speak up
you have to share it you can't no one
can read in between the lines you can't
expect that person to figure it out by
looking at you you need to tell them
this is how i feel most loved right this
is what i need to feel loved and i see
so many couples that get scared about
saying this or doing this well there
it's like hard for your ego because
being able to have enough vulnerability
and openness to say to your wife
i need you to tell me i've got this
right like words of a question that i
need words of affirmations and you know
the ego goes oh no i don't really need
that for my wife
but you have to share it if you don't
tell them that how are they going to
know you've got to put your ego aside
and be really open and honest what is
the power of service and how can we
without going to an ashram how can we
take our strengths and really give them
purpose and meaning
yeah so
one of the biggest things with service
in the ashram is service is a part of
your daily routine so there is no choice
about whether you serve or not
so that's a really great way to live
because you're almost exposed to lots of
different types of service so some of
that would be cooking
for the homeless or underprivileged
children who don't have access to warm
meals some of it would be building
sustainable villages inside which people
can live and villagers can find a home
and an economy so you're always
connected to doing something for others
but if i was going to ask a monk why are
we doing this what would they say
they would say because i believe that
you have to see how you can be useful to
others so the dalai lama probably puts
the best that
really we're born to help others
and if we can't help them at least don't
hurt them
and to me that really sums it up
that we're born to help others we're
born with different gifts with different
geniuses with different talents to
improve the lives of others
and the question i always get from
someone in the audience who wants to ask
me an awkward question will be and
there's always one right and so the
person will say well jay how does
someone who has nothing in india or
africa do this like someone in in like a
really slum situation or a village
situation and that always they'll always
pick on india and africa i'm not saying
those and i'll be like no but this isn't
for them i'm speaking to an audience
that has
an education that has resources that has
network like i'm speaking to people who
can make a difference so anyone who is
in that area of society
has a responsibility so anything that
you're given in life you're seen as a
caretaker of
and the way you take the best care of it
is that you use it in the service of
others and that purifies you from
becoming attached to it and it feeling
like it actually eats you alive
and feeds your ego
as opposed to you now being purified and
cleansed of wealth success fame status
or time
or whatever you have an energy
and you're now using it for the highest
cause so that's what they would say they
would say it's the highest cause
of using what i've been given
in the service of others whatever you've
been given so we played this game in the
monastery where every time you lose to
your mind you put a scoreboard up and
you put a one for the mind and zero for
you when you lose to the mind meaning
what like so let's say you make a
commitment so i make a commitment that
i'm not gonna eat sugar and then you do
20 20 and i do the mind beating the mind
beats me to it so i'm gonna put a one
for the mind and a zero for me great
it's great it's competing with yourself
in a good way it's fun yeah and people
do this with like i guess now with like
dollar jars or whatever like you put a
dollar in
but that doesn't make sense because you
end up making money every time you swear
so but if you beat your mind and you put
it it's great yes so you have to start
learning the tricks of your mind
when and how does your mind fool you
into making bad decisions that's good
the zen story about the tea and i love
zen stories and the books full of them
as as you know
the zen story is where a student
approaches a zen master and a teacher
and is complaining about all the
challenges in their life
and everything they've got going on
and feels like they also have a sense of
ego if they know everything that's
happening
and the zen master sees a cup that's
full there
and starts pouring tea into this cup
and the cup just starts overflowing and
the student's looking at it going like
what are you doing like how does this
make any sense
and and the zen master says well you're
just like this cup
right i can't put any more in you can't
take any more in because you're already
full like you think you're full you
think you're done and and that's the
point that you have to always go back to
that student mindset you have to always
go back to that emptiness and i think
one of the reasons why we struggle with
that is we think that when we're full
we're safe
our ego makes us believe that when
you're full when you think you know it
all that's when you're safe
the craziest thing is that's when you're
at your weakest
and i think that's what we all miss that
when you think if you think of any
company that's ever thought that they
had figured it out that is when they
were at their most
weakest point if there's a fighter in a
boxing match that thinks that they have
perfected this game
that's one of their weakest when
you're in a relationship and you think
oh my life is perfect and everything's
going great that's when you're at your
weakest but we find safety in certainty
when actually that's what makes us
complacent and lose the plot so that
story illustrates the need
to always reconnect not that we're empty
that we have nothing
but that there is so much more to gain
there is so much more to learn the ego
makes you think you're untouchable and
the ego makes you think that
you are you know that nothing about you
can can ever go wrong or you're you're
perfect or not even that but the ego can
bring you down nothing can hurt you
when the moment you think you
can't be brought down you will be
brought down the moment you think that
you kind of one of my teachers would
always pray
that he never
and he's been a monk for 40 years he
would always pray
that he would never
fall to his temptations
and we said to him you haven't fallen to
your temptation for 40 years why do you
pray for that he goes i haven't fallen
because i pray for it wow now he was
like because i pray for it because i'm
not just because i think it's gonna yeah
he's aware and there's a beautiful story
of um benjamin franklin where he talks
about before he died i believe he had 13
or 14 precepts these were qualities that
he wanted to
gain live by and gain so like simplicity
integrity virtues all these powerful
things
and he was asked when he was on his
deathbed which was the one he didn't
accomplish and he said the last one that
was humility i've always had a rule
since i started that all my videos are
70 complete so that's my rule yes it's
70 that's all you're getting yeah
there's words that i say wrong there's
fumbles there may be a few mistakes here
and there the editing may be slow but
it's like my rule was 70 because that
journey from 70 or 75 to 99
could take
decades yeah you could never it could i
would never release something and i
remember in 2016 after my first ever
video one of my first videos that went
viral
i actually got so scared because it was
almost like oh i have to live up to that
now so i remember not creating yeah and
so i went from creating one video a week
to create one video a month and guess
what i learned less
i was engaging less to connect with my
audience to understand what they needed
and what i was giving yeah and i was
trying less ideas which meant that i
wasn't learning learning i wasn't
growing at all i wasn't progressing and
the world was being taken from getting
more beauty from which came from a place
of not thinking like that which came
from a place of not trying to be perfect
exactly the original video that did well
came from a genuine place of just
wanting to serve and trying to figure it
out and then all of a sudden we're not
serving anymore so good and so i was
like okay this doesn't make any sense
and i was like actually and then last
year when we started making more videos
i can honestly handle my heart say that
when we started doing three videos a
week i started to learn so much more
yeah i was like oh i really like it when
i write like this and i really like it
when i create like this and the audience
really responds when i share it this way
and i was learning so much more yeah and
i was feeling more fulfilled by making
more mistakes but learning more so my
mistakes increased yeah but your
learning increase too
which which was a much more
fulfilling place to be even though it
was tough at times but it was fulfilling
it was a ceo
of a very large car manufacturer and he
was known to be extremely successful
very productive very effective but the
one thing he was failing at is that his
employees really didn't like working for
him because he worked late how many of
you feel that way
oh perfect that's good so no one here
finishes late or everyone's managers are
in the room whichever whichever way you
want to take it it's up to you right
it's up to you uh i don't know
so
that was one of his challenges that his
his employees hated work for him because
they all left late because of him he
used to work until 10 p.m every evening
so they would leave just after him true
story right they used to leave just
after him so one of his uh assistants
she came and said this to him she said
you know morale's a bit down
everyone's struggling at work you know
we're losing a few people a few people
are quitting their work you know people
they're not well they don't feel like
their health is being taken care of
they're not spending enough time with
their families you really need to
consider this
he said okay leave it with me we'll
figure it out we'll figure it out
from the next week on a monday
this gentleman who left at 10 pm every
night
got up out of his desk at 6 pm he packed
his bag switched off his computer
left the office jumped into his car and
all the employees at this time are like
peeking out the window you know just
like making sure like figuring out where
is this guy going he pulls into this
beautiful car pulls out and drives away
from the building
it was the first time it ever happened
at 6 p.m
they all decided to wait till 7 pm
before they left
they waited and they left
on tuesday the same thing happened they
looked out the window again he left at 6
p.m again this time they waited till 6
45 and they left
they did the same thing and this
happened for three months where he left
at 6 pm every day
three months later his assistant who
made him aware of this challenge she
came back to him and she said to him i'm
really confused about something she said
you've been leaving
four hours earlier every single day but
you're not behind on your calls you're
not behind on your emails and you're
still performing at the same level if
not better than when you were leaving on
time and she said how are you managing
to do this are you working at home
how are you managing this he said let me
tell you something interesting
he said every day i get into my car at 6
p.m i drive out he said i take a drive
for an hour he said i take that drive i
listen to music i re-energize he said i
sometimes go for a bit of a walk at the
park as well he said i come back fresher
at 7 p.m and i work for three more hours
and he said if it helps them knowing
that i've left at 6 p.m so that they can
have a better life and have the values
that they want and value what they want
to give their time to
that doesn't mean i've got to give up
what i value my time to he said i love
my work i love being here till 10 p.m
i'm extremely ambitious i love being
here but they should also love being
where they are
and that to me is a incredible example
of how someone actually lives foregoing
the perception of others even though he
changed his own life to help other
people they'll never perceive him that
way they just think he's changed his
mind and he goes home early they don't
realize the struggle that he's putting
in and that's what i've realized whether
you're putting in struggle or sacrifice
never look for the validation or
approval of others
to validate that sacrifice or that
struggle
because they don't need to understand
anyway it's always been your inner
journey it's always been part of your
inner growth and i remember when i made
the decision to become a monk after
business school all my friends were like
what the hell are you doing right we
just finished and everyone's going off
to work at goldman sachs and different
banks consulting firms etc i think a few
people came to google as well and they
all said to me they said they said what
do you mean you're becoming a monk like
what does that mean like who graduates
and thinks about that and i remember
having to detach and when i reflect and
i'd love for you to do this reflect on
some of the best decisions you've made
on your life
ask yourself what decision did you make
what did people say about it and what
was going on in your mind i've learned
through doing that exercise it's a much
longer exercise it can take days and we
do it in our coaching exercises i've
learned that the best decisions in my
life have been the biggest risks
everyone's disagreed with me but i've
been hell-bent on making it happen
and so now when i see an opportunity
like that i do it because i realize that
that's the pattern of the philosophy of
my life when i make decisions that are
big risks no one agrees with me and it
doesn't fit with what society is saying
those work out to be my best decisions
in life
and i'm not saying that that's your
pattern i'm saying that you have a
pattern and a rhythm as well and it's
part of your journey to find it when
you're feeling anxious what's happening
is that your mind is either rushing to
the past
or it's predicting and projecting the
future so you're either anxious about
something that you experienced before or
you're feeling really nervous and
anxious about something that might or
could happen in the future the best way
to come back into the present moment is
the five four three two one method
you want to start off
by looking around wherever you are and
noticing the five things you can see it
could be the windows
the walls the ceilings you then want to
focus on the four things you can touch
it could be something you're wearing and
you really want to feel the texture it
could be what you're sitting on just
noticing it and really grounding
yourself and holding on to that then
it's about three things you can hear it
could be nothing
it could be white noise
then the two things you can smell in
hell it could be a scent you're wearing
it could be a flower and then finally
the one thing you can taste when you
practice this it brings you back into
the present moment
and helps you
not focus on the anxiety of the
nervousness but on taking action from
exactly where you are
[Music]
what
everyone
[Music]
no
we're like just i think there's the fun
of it
okay so we did it here it goes uh
really proud of what we did it was fun
it was fun doing it a lot of the time
we're trying to control anxiety up here
and what i find is hard about that is
that if you feel like you've got brain
fog or you're feeling cloudy it becomes
really difficult to find clarity i find
using external things can be huge for me
i love diffusers and candles because a
diffuser is
infusing the whole environment with a
beautiful scent and it truly changes
your mind if you walk into a space just
think of a spa as soon as you walk in
you feel different because of the scent
it could just be a normal room but the
center of lavender sand or wood any of
these essential oils can truly calm your
body right down
some people feel that silence creates
anxiety and some people feel that sound
creates anxiety sometimes i like
complete silence it helps me relax and
really hear my thoughts and the thoughts
that i want to focus on and sometimes i
need to turn on some meditation music
some ambient music just to have that
impact on me
please use music in your environments in
different rooms in your home to help you
achieve different emotions and feelings
that you want to feel at that time terry
pratchett a famous author whether you've
read stuff or not a famous author he
said
that people feel
that stories are defined by people but
actually it's the other way around
people are defined by stories
when you're listening to me today i've
shared so many stories with you because
we define ourselves by the stories we
tell ourselves on a daily basis the
story you wake up to will be the story
that will be the story of your day
right if you wake up and you tell
yourself a positive story you'll have a
positive day you wake up tell yourself a
negative story you'll have a negative
day positive and negative thoughts are
like seeds that either grow weeds or
plants
right
they grow inside of us throughout the
day any time you plant something it's
like planting a seed and the more you
water it the more you think about it
grows and of course it's negative it's
like a weed and it starts to grow and
grow and grow and of course won't bear
fruits
so really think about that tell yourself
the right stories connect with the right
stories because ultimately the universe
is made up of stories not atoms and
numbers right we all love stories we
read stories your life is a living story
that you're writing every day and i
genuinely mean that after i've completed
my work day when i finished all of my
tasks the last thing i do is check my
schedule for the next day now i'm one of
those people that follows their schedule
to a tea i believe it makes life simple
when i get my schedule out and look at
the next day i can think about how i'm
going to feel have i got too much or too
little on that do i want to add or edit
something it gives me perspective and
allows me to get a glance on the next
day so i can rearrange or reorganize
based on the energy i feel today
sometimes we feel so tired and exhausted
but without making that change in edit
we take that exhaustion in the next day
the other reason why i like looking
ahead is that it gives me an opportunity
to mentally prepare i may have a podcast
the next day and there's a guest that
i'm really excited about and i may have
to calm my nerves or sometimes it's an
event or a meeting that i'm looking
forward to and i just want to go over
the bullet points before i go to bed it
gives me an opportunity to rehearse the
day in advance and often i'll even sit
and do a short visualization just to
imagine how tomorrow will look when i
first joined the ashram i was asked to
do a lot of cleaning and in the
beginning i found it tedious and a waste
of time what if i could be serving
humanity what if i could be reading a
book what if i could be studying and
making notes and i had all these excuses
in my mind but of course i'd chosen to
be a monk and therefore i was encouraged
to clean
and i started to find that cleaning did
so much for my mind and recently i
looked at some studies that actually
backed that up there are so many
benefits of cleaning in a physical space
that will also clear out your mind a
recent study from ucla by saxby and
repety found that cleaning gives you a
better sense of control over your
environment and engages your mind in a
repetitive activity that can have a
calming effect emotional intelligence to
me
is being able
to be aware of yourself self-awareness
being able to know yourself that's the
highest form of eq right like being able
to say i know when i'm at my best i know
when i struggle and i know when this is
a limiting belief or not and then being
able to process all of that so we're not
helping people
we are i love saying this because it it
simplifies it but we teach people what
to think not how to think right we tell
them two plus two is four but we don't
tell them how to think about a problem
and that's why when you're faced with a
new problem
and you don't have a formula for it and
you don't have an equation for it you're
like oh i'm stuck right and life's like
that like when in life have you used a
formula to solve a real situation like
even business yeah like when has a
formula helped you yeah but we're taught
that formulas solve equations but we all
know that there's no formula to business
success happiness meaning etc etc etc
how do you deal with it when the doubt
is coming from the people that you
really love and you know they care about
you
yeah it was hard i didn't go to my grad
i graduated but never went to my
graduation ceremony so my mom doesn't
have a picture of me
holding my degree and that was a big
thing for her because i moved to india i
just went so i never went to that and
that was a big thing for her and
actually my parents i'm very grateful my
mom and dad are actually fairly liberal
and supportive of anything i've decided
to do it's my extended family that's had
more opinions and been more involved and
kind of stirring stuff up with my
parents if that makes sense so the way i
dealt with it was always asking myself
these questions around
you know
is someone invested in my future is
someone gonna be there for me when i'm
struggling and there's someone paying my
bills like those are my three checking
system of who matters in life like your
soul your mind and your paycheck
and i think the biggest thing i asked
myself was just
am i gonna look back on if i don't do
this am i going to look back going back
to the alexander the great story
am i going to look back on my deathbed
and say
my mom and dad held me back
because i may say i'm going to do it for
them i'm not going to do this decision
because i respect them and love them but
am i going to hate them in the end or be
bitter towards them or feel a negative
feeling towards them because i feel they
held me back
and if that's the truth i never want to
feel that about my parents they're
incredible
so i need to go and take the
responsibility to make this shift
and i think the truth is that
when we think people are holding us back
it's just us not taking responsibility
for us to push forward like that's all
it is because the truth is if you really
really really really really want
something right like if someone told you
right now you had to get on a plane and
there's a million dollars in new york no
one would say oh my parents can't afford
to play like no one would say that you
would you would do it if you really
wanted it you'd get on a plane right now
and you'd go pick that million dollars
up so it's our own insecurity that we
reflect onto the people around us and i
think it's really important i get it
there are people who are toxic around us
i get it i had that too there were
people who were just like
literally people said to me like you
realize you're going to fail at being a
monk you realize when you come back no
one's going to hire you you realize when
you come back no one's going to want to
be with you you really you know there
are so many things like people like you
know you're going to be socially dead
like no one's going to care where you
are there was so much of that but it
didn't get amplified because i was
strong in my conviction so the way i
dealt with it was just keep
strengthening your conviction
rather than trying to weaken the
argument because the the opinions of
others will get weakened when you
strengthen your own right that's how it
works you don't weaken someone else's to
strengthen your own another story i'll
tell you because i love this too and it
shows so
and and he'll like this story so marcus
aurelius if you haven't read meditations
by marcus aurelius highly recommend it
marcus aurelius emperor meditations is
his personal journal
and one of the stories that i love about
him that that comes up in a few
hollywood movies too is that once when
he was walking through the roman town
square
he used to have his advisor follow him
around and whenever people would glorify
him and praise him
the person's job was to come into his
ear and whisper you're just a man you're
just a man just to remind him just to
remind him in that moment where you just
you know in that moment where you just
feel like your ego is just going through
the roof because everyone's saying
you're amazing you changed my life etc
a to remember you're just a man and i
would add to that remember the people
who made you that right remember the
people who gave you that and so that's
how i've learned to balance ego
is by any time i'm glorified or praised
or appreciated or recognized i'm passing
that off to my teachers guides mentors
the universe and
accepting it on their behalf
so if i receive an award i actually
don't think it's mine i'm accepting it
on behalf of everyone who made me the
way i am it's beautiful whether it was
positive or negative too so we're so
used to in our life having instant
judgment defining a moment and giving it
a label good or bad in the moment and i
thought how do i present a concept to
the world
where we can laugh at ourselves and
realize that sometimes our instant
judgment or our instant labeling
processor isn't always correct yes how
do we how do we get that so this script
or narrative that i shared in this video
is on a gentleman who goes to buy these
cookies
because he feels like having a few
cookies because his flight's delayed and
he sits down to eat these cookies and
the gentleman opposite him where you're
sitting right now starts to take cookies
out as well
and he's saying how's this guy and the
guy looks a little rugged he looks a
little scruffy he doesn't look put
together so naturally all of our biases
our unconscious biases start coming up
and stemming up we start thinking oh he
looks a little shady or maybe he doesn't
have money that's why he's taking my
cookies and we have this impression of i
me and mine these are my cookies how can
he take them
only to realize when he leaves that your
cookie box was in your bag
and that gentleman was sharing his
cookies with you
and then this person has this epiphany
or this moment of realizing how quick he
was to judge but how wrong he was and i
think all of us in different ways have
different moments in our life where
whether we misjudged a person the first
time we met them or we misjudged someone
because of the first thing they said to
us or we had a friend that now is our
best friend but our first impression was
oh they're a loser and all of a sudden
now we think they're amazing i literally
skip over negative comments genuinely
since day one and i remember reading in
the starting so i'll add this there have
been times when i've looked at negative
comments and they're like huh that's
quite funny like you know it's
funny they're true but overall i try to
respond to everyone who said something
positive and i rarely put any energy in
to put anyone who put anything negative
because i don't want to change their
mind they're entitled to their belief
they're okay to feel that way and if i
feel like it's good feedback i'll take
it on board but if i feel like it's just
someone being a keyboard warrior and you
know doesn't like me and saying what
they want then i'm not going to take
that seriously yeah it's pretty easy to
tell the difference between the two 100
if there's some authenticity and truth
behind it it's a much different comment
than just unabashed hate yeah absolutely
and i've had everything from he has a
wind machine in his videos to make sure
his hair slides right like i've had that
that angle and i'm like you don't have i
don't i just went out on a really windy
day this is my exclusive on the podcast
this is an excuse for the podcast i do
not have a wind machine uh but i've had
everything from that and i laughed at
that i thought that was a hilarious
comment
through to the other side of just like
you know i don't agree with you and i
don't agree with the point you're making
this is my point and i'm like yeah you
know what i had three minutes to explain
that and i missed that point like you're
right you know i agree with you if i had
a podcast like this i could have
explained myself
so you know i but i do think that we do
drag our own selves down we
put all the energy into the negativity
and amplify it
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there